wenn sich das bestätigen sollte haben
wir es mit einer echten revolution der
teilchenphysik zu tun
ein ungarisches forschungsteam hat
hinweise auf eine neue fünfte
naturgewalt aufgespürt konkret geht es
um ein bislang unbekanntes teilchen mit
der bezeichnung x17 das nach angaben der
forscherin bei der analyse eines helium
atoms entstanden ist experten von
experten weltweit überprüfen das ganze
jetzt mit hochdruck stehen wir kurz vor
dem wendepunkt in der teilchenphysik und
kommen wir so endlich der mysteriösen
dunklen materie auf die schliche tricks
um science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's bisher
sind vier natürliche kräfte bekannt da
ist zum einen die elektromagnetische
kraft dann die gravitation und hinzu
kommen noch zwei nuklearer
wechselwirkungen nämlich die so genannte
starke kernkraft und die sogenannte
schwache kernkraft die beide auf ebene
der atomkerne eine entscheidende rolle
spielen ein ungarisches forschungsteam
mischt das ganze jetzt kräftig auf denn
bei experimenten mit atomkern wollen die
forschenden nämlich nichts geringeres
als eine fünfte naturgewalt aufgespürt
haben wenn sich das tatsächlich
bestätigen sollte haben wir es mit einer
echten sensation zu tun denn damit
könnten die fachleute nicht nur die
dunkle materie erforschen
unser gesamtes verständnis des
universums und der dort herrschenden
kräfte würde sich damit möglicherweise
um 180 grad drehen aber von vorne
das ungarische forschungsteam um den
physiker attila krasznahorkai hatte bei
seinen experimenten schon vor drei
jahren 2016 ungewöhnliche beobachtungen
gemacht damals hatten die fachleute den
zerfall des beryllium isotops im visier
dabei entstanden photonen die sich in
sekundenbruchteilen in ein elektron und
das entsprechende gegenstück das
positron um wann also materie und
antimaterie vereinfacht gesagt
beobachteten die fachleute bei einem
bestimmten trennungs winkel ein
mysteriöses verhalten liegt dieser
winkel der elektronen positronen paare
bei etwa 140 grad passiert etwas sehr
sehr seltsam es eigentlich sollten immer
weniger teilchen bei größeren winkeln
ausgesendet werden
doch bei 140 grad gibt es einen
sprunghaften anstieg schon damals also
gab es möglicherweise eine erste spur so
die fachleute
handelt es sich um ein völlig neues
bisher unbekanntes teilchen spricht
diese mysteriöse beobachtung sein da für
eine fünfte urkraft die ungarischen
fachleute gaben nicht auf und machten
sich daran weitere beweise für diese
these zusammen für aktuelles experiment
nutzen sie einen teilchenbeschleuniger
und produziert den hut von zwei wochen
millionen energetisch angeregte helium
gerne auch diese senden photonen aus die
sich innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit in ein
elektron und ein positronen also das
positiv geladene gegenstück antimaterie
umwandeln und das ungarische
forschungsteam hat auch hier wie der
mysteriöse beobachtung gemacht denn
manchmal verlief das experiment wieder
anders als es unseren bisherigen
physikalischen gesetze verlangen würden
auch hier trennten sich mehr elektronen
und positronen paare in einem
mysteriösen winkel von annähernd 100 15
grad der so mit hilfe von bisherigen
modellen nicht erklärt werden kann
auch attila krasznahorkai war anfangs
selbst skeptisch ich habe die daten auf
verschiedene arten analysiert aber das
signal ist nicht verschwunden
dieses signal kann nach angaben des
ungarischen physikers nicht mit der
ausgesendeten gammastrahlung erklärt
werden deswegen die vermutung dass ein
bisher unbekanntes teilchen dahinter
steckt dass durch den helium kern
erzeugt wurde und die ergebnisse des
experiments lassen sogar einige
rückschlüsse auf diese sonderling zu
die daten sprechen dafür dass ist etwa
33 mal so schwer sein muss wie ein
elektron und dabei eine energie von etwa
17 millionen elektronenvolt aufweisen
muss deswegen auch die bezeichnung x17
doch was steckt wirklich dahinter fest
steht die gesamte physik community
weltweit steht kopf und versucht dieses
rätsel zu entschlüsseln
handelt es sich hier um ein messfehler
oder haben wir es tatsächlich mit einer
waschechten sensation zu tun die uns
bislang verborgenen dimensionen eröffnet
kleist die studie von chrysler und
seinem team hat bislang noch nicht das
so genannte peer review verfahren
durchlaufen also unabhängige
forscherinnen und forscher haben die
studie noch nicht nach objektiven
kriterien bewertet doch genau das steht
noch aus und erst nach der offiziellen
begutachtung werden wir also genaueres
wissen einige fachleute weltweit
jedenfalls sind skeptisch und das hat
vor allem etwas mit der vergangenheit
des ungarischen forschung instituts zu
tun denn schon seit 13 jahren seit 2006
werden von ihr immer mal wieder neue
sensationsheischende entdeckung
vermeldet spätere messungen konnten
diese
lange aber noch nie bestätigen und das
macht den ruf und das ansehen in der
wissenschafts community
verständlicherweise nicht unbedingt
besser
attila krasznahorkai spricht offen über
diese fehler und betont dass diesmal
alles andere wie anders lief zum einen
sei für das aktuelle experiment ein
anderer beschleuniger genutzt worden
und zum anderen hatte es damals wohl
schwierigkeiten bei der interpretation
der daten gegeben dazu der ungarische
physiker seitdem haben wir die energie
erhöht und unsere detektoren verbessert
die aktuellen daten bezüglich des neuen
teilchens x17 sein zitat solide
falls sich die behauptung aus ungarn
bestätigt würde dies bedeuten dass
vorherige experimente kläglich
gescheitert sind dazu der physiker jesse
thaler vom renommierten massachusetts
institute of technology existiert x17
dann wäre es den detektoren
jahrzehntelang entgangen es müsse daher
auf eine sehr ungewöhnliche weise mit
der bekannten materie wechselwirken
andere fachleute aus den usa halten es
dagegen für möglich dass das ungarische
forschungsteam recht behält und die nun
möglicherweise neu entdeckten teilchen
träger einer fünften urkraft sein
könnten
falls sich dies durch weitere
experimente bestätigen lässt würde uns
dies auch bei der suche nach der dunklen
materie weiter nach vorne bringen und
auch andere kräfte des universums
könnten so besser verstanden werden
fünfte dimension entdeckt ist unser
universum ganz anders eine ähnlich
bahnbrechende entdeckung also anklicken
anschauen und natürlich abonnieren und
zwar klicks und science fiction teils es
noch nicht gemacht haben sollte die
serie auf youtube kostenlos also bis
dann bleibt dran